foreign
author named Andrea Bartz reignited a
familiar conversation over the weekend
when she tweeted about the joys of being
quote Child free here's what her post
said uh she's first quoting people on
the other side she says Child free
people will never experience the joy of
watching their child touch grass for the
first time and she responds to that by
saying okay but do parents know the joy
of being 37 and sleeping in and drinking
coffee in silence then leaving the house
on a moment's notice whenever the f I
want
every few months we get another attempt
by a childless woman it is almost always
a woman to try and convince us that it's
actually a great idea to live only for
yourself and die by yourself and make
yourself into an ancestral dead end
leaving behind no progeny and no Legacy
and every once in a while the woman
making this case is someone other than
Chelsea Handler but whether it's Chelsea
Handler or not the argument is always
effectively the same if you don't have
kids you can sleep in relax drink coffee
in peace leave the house whenever you
want and enjoy conveniences and luxuries
that are beyond the reach of people with
children
now the first and most obvious response
to this kind of claim is that it's
simply untrue it's a false premise
parents can and do know what it's like
to do all of those things sleep in drink
coffee peacefully Etc we know because we
experience those things before we had
kids and once our kids get older we'll
have just as much access to them as
Andrea Bartz does
in fact all of the luxuries she mentions
really only become difficult when you
have young kids and this is almost
always the case when Child free quote
unquote people talk about what they
imagine the irritations and sufferings
of parents must be they're almost always
talking about parenting young children
if your kids are say 10 or older however
there's no reason why you can't sleep in
or enjoy silence in your home or you
know even leave the house without much
hassle
so if these things do fall Out Of Reach
it's only it's only for in most cases
maybe a 10-year window or so
in my case the window's a little bit
longer because we have 87 kids still
it's not a permanent situation
and even when you have young kids even
if you have 87 young kids you can still
experience the joy of sleeping in and
relaxing and so on just requires a
little bit of a little bit of planning
you have to hire babysitters you have to
get the grandparents to watch the kids
so you can spend a few days just with
your spouse or something there are many
ways to orchestrate some relaxation time
no matter how many kids you have no
matter how young they are you just have
to put in some effort and some planning
and be intentional to make those sorts
of Joys available in fact I would argue
that only parents of young kids can
experience those Joys however fleetingly
sure 37 year old woman without kids can
wake up late in the morning and have a
cup of coffee in silence but this is not
any great treat for her it's just her
life it's her everyday she has nothing
to compare it to
I had many quiet cups of coffee before I
had kids but I didn't find actual joy in
those moments because it's all I ever
knew
now you take it for granted
yeah I admit I don't get very many Quiet
Moments at this stage of my life but
when I do get a single moment like that
I guarantee I enjoy it a thousand times
more than Andrea has enjoyed all of her
Quiet Moments combined so she has me be
on quantity but I'm winning on quality
it's a simple and perhaps uh kind of
depressing reality of the human
condition that we can't really
appreciate something unless we've
experienced its opposite
you know unless you have something to
compare it to you can't really
appreciate it you just can't you can't
really enjoy being full unless you've
been really hungry you can't enjoy lying
in bed unless you've been very tired you
can't really enjoy walking out of the
house without hassle unless you've
actually experienced
trying to walk out of the house with a
gaggle of small children who can't find
their shoes or jackets and are wearing
clothing that has somehow become filthy
and stained in the 30 minutes since you
put it on them
uh
if you've experienced that then yes in
the moments when you get to walk out of
the house and everything's fine you go
wow that's a relief
what this means is that only people with
children can actually experience the
kinds of Joys that are supposedly only
available to people without them life
has an ironic way about it you know in
that way
besides when it comes to quiet
you know not all moments of quiet are
made the same so for example last night
at a you know about 10 o'clock
Andrea Bartz I assume was was most
likely in her house alone wherever she
lives and uh and I'm sure it was very
quiet
and I was in my house where I live and
it was also very quiet
but it was a fall kind of quiet it was a
warm quiet not an empty and cold quiet
my children were asleep my wife had gone
to bed I went up to my kids rooms I
checked on them tucked them back in and
then I sat on my couch and I read a book
the house was as quiet as a house can
get just as it is is every night even
though it was full of kids
so we were both relaxing in the silence
but mine was not a solitary silence mine
was the silence you get after you tucked
your children into bed and kiss them
good night
hers was the silence that you get when
you have no children to tuck in and
nobody to kiss goodnight
and I'll take mine any day I'll take
both my loud and my quiet my no noise
and my silence
there's joy available in both and I
think to a much greater degree is your
cell phone in desperate need of
replacement you know the signs short
battery life so you have to have a
charger on hand all the time crack
screen that gives you glass splinters
well it's time to put that old phone to
rest and upgrade to a new 5G Samsung
Galaxy from Pure Talk for free get a
free 5G Samsung Galaxy with two day
battery life edge to edge display and
Ultra strong Gorilla Glass when you sign
up for Pure talks unlimited talk text
and 15 gig data plan for just 35 dollars
a month plus it comes with a mobile
hotspot get all the data you could ever
need for half the price of the big
carriers on America's Most Dependable 5G
Network go to puretalk.com Walsh for
your free super durable 5G Samsung
Galaxy when you switch to pure talk
again visit puretalk.com Walsh and make
the switch to my cell phone company Pure
Talk the official Wireless partner of
the daily wire but that's the key word
you know available and I made this point
before but I think it's worth repeating
because it's something that um quote
Child free Advocates seem to miss I
think many people miss it in many
contexts in modern society
now they're correct when they point out
that
parenting brings all kinds of challenges
that might cause parents to feel
irritated and overwhelmed
there's plenty in Parenthood that can
cause real suffering I mean all that is
true it's also true that some parents
are never happy they regret having kids
they resent their kids for existing
that that that's their appearance like
that no doubt about it they're miserable
and their kids will rightly grow to hate
them for being so miserable which will
only Heap more misery on top of Misery
all of that is true
but that's because the joy of Parenthood
is available but it's not imposed on us
against our will it will not sprinkle
down on us like rain from the clouds
it's made available but you have to
choose to experience it and choosing Joy
is all about Focus what are you deciding
to focus on what are you paying
attention to
you can take joy in those hectic
mornings when your house is full of life
and noise and energy you could take that
could be a joyful thing or you can focus
on the fact that you can't drink a cup
of coffee in peace
you can pay attention to what you aren't
getting what you can't do or you can pay
attention to the beauty in those moments
that that's how you take the joy that's
available or not
you can take it or you can turn it down
that's it life is presenting it says you
here's some Joy you can feel it right
now if you want
but a lot of times people say no because
I'd rather be focused on this thing that
annoys me
now this is about as self-helpy as
you'll ever hear me sound but there's an
important point in it which is that
literally all of the joys of a child
free quote-unquote life are absolutely
available to those with children you
just might have to work a little harder
to get them or you might have to wait a
little while and be a little patient
but the joys of Parenthood are
absolutely not available to those who
are not parents
it's a it's a whole category an entire
genre of joy that is Out Of Reach for
the childless
whether they want to choose it or not
it's just not available life it's not
it's not an option on the menu
now I'm not trying to rub it in or gloat
I'm just trying to convey to anyone
who's hesitant to have kids because
they're worried that they'll be unhappy
that you'll only be unhappy if you
choose to be but a whole new level of
happiness will be open to you if you
choose that instead
that's what Andrea Bartz
and so many others who brag about being
quote Child free don't see and that's
why they are today again canceled hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there